the Beyond Good and Evil 2 development
team is ready for another check-in this
time highlighting their progress on
player movement and showing new gameplay
of both on foot and spaceship piloting
action the player is a easy pirate so we
have to kind of very important gameplay
the ship itself and the character itself
one is moving on his route on his feet
and the fact that we can use his stuff a
bit like the first this year so we are
working all the mechanics out staff we
are working on all the mechanic
locomotion our our character is moving
we have the jet pack so good way to to
move in three actually you can also
board the ship so you are inside you see
any mothership trying to fight your way
through the different rooms and you have
your jet pack so you can jump pen escape
and maybe come back to Pho after this
it's up to you actually another nice
thing with pirates is that there are
very mysterious and Beyond Good and Evil
One now inside case they were not like
we went you were not able to see them in
the world so it was very mysterious and
it is part of things we will explain or
discover is what happened to the pirates
being evasive is one of the things
pirates do best but the team knows that
when you're playing with friends you
won't want to lose track of them so
easily and Beyond Good and Evil 2 we
have huge space spaces so we have a big
speed and it's really odd multiplayer to
follow each other at low speed so you
already quickly we lose your friends and
that's how you have the Armada because
in the Armada you can look behind your
friend the design of the game is pretty
advanced now we we know where we are
going so we're on this phase of taking a
lot of things today so it could with you
so sometime we see some very fun and
stuff coming for you to stay up-to-date
on Beyond Good and Evil 2 and talk with
the development team about what you'd
like to see in the game go to BGE
game.com to sign up for the space monkey
program then subscribe to this youtube
channel to be sure to catch the latest
videos
you